Dr. Zakia, what is the essential
difference between the term toba and the
term
meaning I believe forgiveness?
Mak means forgiveness and
means seeking forgiveness.
The meaning is of two types. One type of
meaning is when it comes along with the
word tba and the other meaning is when
it comes individually. When it comes
individually, it has one and the same
meaning. The meaning can be
interchanged. It means exactly the same.
But the scholars they say when it comes
along with the word toba thenikar it
means that we are seeking protection
from the past evils that we used to do
and taa when it comes along with it
means that we are pain to Allah subhana
wa t'ala and we are seeking protections
from the things which we may indulge in
future. So basically stikfar means
seeking protection from the things of
the past which we wish to do and tba
seeking protection for the things which
may unfortunately we may indulge in
future. So this is the basic difference.
If it comes separately the meaning is
one and the same. If it comes together
then it has two different meanings.
>> It's good we're going through this
technical definition phase in every
episode. I think this is something which
is missing amongst the brothers and
sisters is the real understanding of the
basic terms. The next question really
for me would be why is it such a special
thing to seek repentance during this
holy blessed month of Ramadan. This
month is special
because Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he
forgives his slaves his servants the
maximum in this month. Therefore it is
given the title Ramadan the month of
forgiveness and our beloved prophet
wasallam said it's mentioned in the
hadith ofi in the book of fasting hadith
number 682 where our beloved prophet
wasallam said that when the first night
of Ramadan comes
the devils and the demons they are
chained and the gates of hell are closed
not even a single gate is open and the
gates of heaven they open not even a
single gate disclosed and the caller he
calls to the people that oh those who
want to do good please come and those
who are doing evil please desist and
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he ransoms his
slaves and he does that every night of
Ramadan and our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he further
said it's mentioned in say had ofdi
had number 3545
where the beloved prophet wasallam once
he goes goes on the pulpit before g of
kudbat and he says a mean amen a mean
thrice. So the people asked that, "Oh
messenger, why?" So the messenger of
Allah subhanaa tala says that archangel
Gabriel had come to him and said that
anyone who does not have his sins
forgiven after Ramadan is approached and
enters the hellfire ask Allah to keep a
distance from him. And then Gabriel says
to Muhammad wasallam say amen. Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says amen.
Means it's unfortunate that anyone
witnesses the month of Ramadan and does
not have his sins forgiven because this
is the month of forgiveness and our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's mentioned in say
Bkari volume number three in the book of
fasting had number 1901 that if anyone
fasts in the complete month of Ramadan
with belief and seeking the reward of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala all his passes
will be forgiven. That's the reason
Ramadan is called as a month of
forgiveness.
>> Subhan Allah. And Dr. Zakya, we used to
have a saying back in the days before I
embraced Islam that I wish it could be
Christmas every day. And I'm going to
say I wish it could be Ramadan every
day. Now, more appropriately, what about
the necessities
of seeking repentance especially during
this holy month of Ramadan? And what are
the merits of seeking forgiveness? It is
compulsory for every believer of Allah
subhanana wa tala for every Muslim that
if he does any sin whether minor or
major small or big he should repent as
soon as possible. Repentance is
compulsory for any sin that you've
committed. And Allah says in the Quran
in surah chapter number 24 verse number
31. Oh you believe turn alltogether in
repentance to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
so that you may attain bliss so that you
may become successful so that you may
enter paradise. Allah gives a similar
message in surahim chapter number 66
verse number 8 that oh you believe turn
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala with
sincere repentance
and Allah further says in the Quran in
surah hahud chapter number 11 verse
number three that ask for forgiveness to
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala and seek his
repentance so that he may do good to
you. Allah says in the Quran in surah
surah chapter number 42 verse number 25
that he accepts repentance and forgives
sins and ask forgiveness for Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is of forgiving and
most merciful and Allah says in the
Quran in surah maida chapter number five
verse number 39 that if the thief if he
repents and if he changes his acts after
repenting If he has changed his acts
then Allah subhanana wa ta'ala turns to
him in forgiveness for Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala is of forgiving and most
merciful. Allah repeats a similar
message in surah maida chapter number 5
verse number 74
that ask Allah subhananaa tala for
forgiveness for he is of forgiving and
most merciful. Besides several verses of
the Quran there are several hadith which
speak about the merit of tabba. For
example, if read the hadith of a beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
say Bkari volume number 8 book of
applications had number 6307 where our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he says that I ask for
forgiveness and repentance more than 17
times a day. Imagine our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam who's the
best of examples who's the best human
being on the face of the earth. He says
that he asked for forgiveness and
repentance of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
more than 70 times a day. It further
mentioned in sah Muslim volume number
four in the book of
Hadit number
where a beloved prophet wasallam said oh
believers you should repent and I repent
every day 100 times to Allah subhanaa
tala. It's mentioned in the hadith of
say Muslim volume number four in the
book of repentance had number 6644 that
our beloved prophet wasallam said that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala stretches out
his hand during the night for the people
who repent for the sins they have
committed from dawn to dusk and Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala stretches out his
hand during the day for the people who
repent for the sins Means they have
committed from dust to dawn until the
sun rises from the west. That means
until the day of resurrection that means
Allah subhanaa tala will forgive your
sins until the day of resurrection
whoever repents. A similar hadith is
mentioned in Sai Muslim point number
four in the book of the Hadith number
where our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that Allah
subhananau wa ta'ala will keep on
forgiving for anyone who repents until
the sun rises from the west that mean
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will forgive
the sins until the day of resurrection
if any of his slaves any of his servants
ask for forgiveness further It's
mentioned in Sai Bkari volume number 8
in the book of Rik had number 6438
where the beloved prophet wasallam said
that if the son of Adam
was given a valley of gold, he would yet
want a second one. And if a second value
of gold is given to him, he would want
the third. For there is nothing that
fills the stomach of the son of Adam
except dust. This shows that the greed
the human beings have and irrespective
of how much nyama Allah gives he always
seeks for more and more rather he should
repent and ask for forgiveness. And
there's a different version of the
hadith I quoted earlier. It's mentioned
in Sai Muslim volume number four in the
book of Dikar had number 6613
where a beloved prophet wasallam said
that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is more
pleased when his servant repents when
his servant asks for forgiveness than a
person who while traveling on his camel
in the desert he stops for rest and he
sleeps beneath a tree and when he wakes
up. He sees his camel lad in with goods.
He's not there. So he climbs on a mound
and he tries to find the camel, he does
not find it. He climbs on the second
mound but yet doesn't find it. He climbs
on the third mound, he doesn't find it.
Then he turns back to the original
position and there he sees his camel
laden with the goods and he's so happy.
So Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is more
happy than a person who finds his lost
camel laden with goods in the desert.
Allah is more happy than that when a
person asks for forgiveness when he
repents. So these are the merits of
repentance and tba. It reminds me of my
own journey to Islam once again month of
Ramadan. This is when I found my fra.
Alhamdulillah.